this day will be scotch in our
memory till after we die
this is going to stick with me for the
rest of my life
the doctor the drummer and the porter
three lives of so many
ripped apart this is their story a month
on
in a few moments few seconds everything
just
blew up and i just remember me
being on the floor because it knocked me
back
on the wall and i just remember being on
the floor doing this
and i could feel my fur my face was
burning so much
i didn't know what was happening to my
face but i felt it burning
and we started walking just to try to
get to a hospital
inside that hospital a routine day was
about to become the most difficult
they'd ever experienced
the damage here wasn't the challenge it
was the number of injured
this desk was like beds
for the injured people this is dr elaine
ayub
on the right dressed for the struggles
of corona
but now dealing with something on a
different level even in the civil war
it wasn't like this 700 in two hours
the youngest one was here in this room
she was dying here it was like my
child when i hear the
father speaking to her alex sue my dear
alex sue
all will be okay i was crying
because never will be never and never
he will see her again i knew that
she was dying one silent cctv image
tells so many stories
the resilience of children must be some
comfort at a time like this
their house didn't survive the blast
but their beds did
and so for these four this is home now
their father moyad is a porter down at
the docks but
fate had brought him home early that day
he's a refugee from syria who'd come to
lebanon for a better life
and now he must pick it all up once
again
um
so what next well the investigation has
hardly moved
the politics is as toxic as ever the
accountability is far away
and the people we lost everything we
lost our relatives
we lost our home we lost on
our money we lost our souls
what's sad is that the government and
the people that are supposed to be in
charge
and of this of the country
they're just turning a blind eye on on
the people
stone sky news